what's going on with Ukraine right now
is the equivalent to like let's say
China decided to go ahead and have
missiles in Mexico pointing at the
United States we would be in Mexico
tomorrow to get those Chinese out that's
essentially what happened with the
Russians and uh Ukraine with NATO and uh
you know Russia Boone's been warning
them forever hey you know NATO's trying
to encroach on Ukraine you better not
let them in better not let them in if
they come in we're going to have
problems and you know zielinski kept
flirting with NATO and they came in and
what did poon do okay well now we're
gonna return on force and my thing is
I'm not on either side but I understand
where Putin is coming from because he's
operating to protect his country he's
operating to protect his National
Security